pranked or started with a man named
Serge Serge has looked at social media
and YouTube for the last year and he's
been experimenting with different
programs and he's been trying to build
an audience him suffer last year but
then it clicked to him that why said I
build audience when I can go to
youtubers to have them come together
work on a project because they're the
ones with the audience and so he came up
with this idea pranked her let's bring
together a dozen YouTube personalities
who fit together have great chemistry
outgoing and can make fools of
themselves and so that's essentially how
prank tour started the the the length of
the prank tour movie is 45 minutes it
was bumped from 30 minutes of 45 minutes
because we filmed that much content and
we definitely cut out a good bit of
content because if we kept everything in
there that we would have wanted to it
have been probably an hour to an hour
and a half and we just didn't have the
time to make that link possible the
chemistry between everybody was mixed
there were some people who just weren't
a good fit for it not because they
weren't creative enough for hardworking
enough but because they're they're just
not right for the environment but the
majority of us the core cast members
that are now the core cast members and
we've been talking before we met at
prank tour we were all friends we all
hung out with each other we all
respected each other and we were all
willing to work with each other already
and so this was a perfect opportunity
for us to do that to be honest with you
the process of filming every day at
prank tour was a little bit of
disorganized and not because of anyone's
fault it came down to a great decision
that serves made the director at the
time from the beginning just wasn't
looking out for the youtubers best
interest he was trying to have us do
things and just didn't make any sense
wanting us to read off scripts to our
viewers that did not make any sense that
then I feel organic and I spoke very
very vocally about that I said I will
not read this script to my viewers this
is not my personality I need bulletin
points not a script so the director was
fired and they brought in a director
last-minute name shay shay is part of
the awkward black girl project and Shay
worked with us each day
to make sure that what we did fit our
personalities fit our character fit what
our audience liked because of shay and
because of the ability for the talent
the youtubers to work with any given
situation to work on their toes even
though was this organized every day we
were just hit the ground running hit the
ground running hit the ground running
hit the ground talk about what we need
to do and then we went and did it one of
the things that were asked for us to do
that didn't quite work out and we
addressed right away was the day of
venice beach swimming with filming they
want to split up in teams and instantly
we felt like our chemistry was being
torn apart and being competed against
one another and we weren't really
performing as well as we wanted to so we
eventually just all group back up
together and start pulling all pranks
together and that chemistry brought us
back to life there was a couple of times
where some of the pranks were well
thought out and I stepped up and I said
I don't believe this prank is going to
work because XY and Z and the director
assistant director in surg they they
took the time to listen to me and at the
end the day they made the right decision
based on what we thought I did end up
taking a leadership role in a very
natural way I didn't say I'm the leader
I'm the boss you gotta listen to me
because the thing is at the end of the
day it wasn't of them listening to me it
was about me listening to them I listen
to everybody in us as soon as I heard
everyone's opinions and questions and
got everyone's perspective I'm a sore
everyone's problems and solutions were
addressed and I brought an overall
perspective that worked for the entire
team not just for the YouTube talent but
also for AMD productions Shay the
director the assistant director they
felt like they could come to me talk to
me and I could go back and talk to the
talent and vice versa on bad days I did
what I could to sit down and listen to
everybody both the production team in
the YouTube talent and I asked what do
you think was bad what was wrong what
could we do to address this but at the
same time I always asked what was good
because even on a bad day there were
good things that happen and you don't
want to forget to get things because as
soon as you forget the good things you
ain't up causing more problems down the
road when you try to address other
problems so by being a by being there to
listen to both the good and the bad we
were able to make a bad day
a better day to following day I believe
people should check out prank tour
because this is not just a simple
YouTube collaboration I know you know
and this is our fault for making it seem
that way but it's not a simple YouTube
collaboration it's youtubers being a
given chance to create premium content
content that Google has been trying to
invest into hundreds of million dollars
and it's not working because they're not
investing into the content creators it
works in situations like philly d it's a
content creator but let's look at some
of these other companies that are giving
5 million dollars and their channels
below so when you give content creators
a chance us a chance to create premium
content and be given the resources
opportunities to do that then we're
really creating a product that has not
been seen before we have came together
in creating a movie a movie about
youtubers working together living
together having fun together and it is
the most organic life changing
experience we ever had as soon as we
left the house we all felt like we're
leaving we were like all breaking apart
as a family it's like when you leave
home for the first time for college
that's what it felt like
you